[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum i just wanted to get a
shot of on the video of ryan sitting
down in the shot so he's like dude i'm
not ready
dude back it up man start over boy
hey thanks this is a special episode we
weren't
we're going to take two weeks off but uh
i figured you know i don't want to lose
an audience
and uh i love this uh this guest if you
haven't seen shawshank redemption and
millions of other things in fact he was
just in that show uh the crown
on netflix he played yeah he was lbj lbj
yeah
yeah he was great he's great uh clancy
brown
great and i got to work with him on the
great brain robbery and the justice
league unlimited years ago
we switched brains he was lex luthor
ironically
and uh i was the flash of course and
that was fun if you don't know anything
about that but you like clancy brown
well you're here so you're gonna
hopefully listen
uh i hope you guys have a brilliant
freaking new year and i just want to say
thank you to everybody
ryan bryce all my lovely patrons
and everybody who listens to the show uh
you know it's just
the show's so important to me now it's
become a big part of my life just with
uh
you know talking about real stuff and i
hope that you know more people find it
and i hope that you guys stick around
and uh i just want to say thank you from
the bottom of my heart for for sticking
around and listening to episodes that
for with guests that you don't even know
and just because you might learn
something we all learn something
ryan what are the handles for inside you
podcast they are at inside of you pod on
twitter
inside of you podcast on instagram and
facebook and uh youtube.com slash inside
of you with michael rosenbaum
youtube.com
inside of you with michael rosenbaum yes
that is awesome ryan edits the episodes
so you can watch them if you don't watch
them you should
and if you're watching listen go listen
and uh i can't say it enough but if when
you write reviews
if you really like an episode and it
means something like you know that was
really good
you could take that minute to just write
a review and also email your friends and
say please
subscribe uh it means the world it
really helps believe it or not
um it does and i want to thank westwood
one for all their lovely support
all the ladies it's mo i work with old
ladies at westwood one kelly and teresa
and agnes and kat
and katrin um
and it's just a great group of people
and i like having
all women in my life because they're
really smart they know what they're
doing
and you just kind of let them do it you
just i defer to you
you know women but again thank you to
everyone and all the patrons out there
who have really
the reason why the show is still on its
feet in the beginning i mean especially
now
tough times and a tough year for
everybody but um they
they stuck with me and they um are so
supportive and uh even when i
send merch boxes to them
and uh i signed to the wrong person and
i have to
and they're understanding very seldom do
i get an email at
hello inside of you podcast.com
hello at instagram.com that's right
do i get a you sign the wrong name
it's usually like hey this is from my
dad for his birthday and his name's not
alicia
so i'm like yeah my bad bro
my mind just goes it's going south man
unless dad realizes he's been alicia the
whole time there he digs deep that's why
i have ryan here folks
also thank you everybody for coming to
our stage it was our biggest stage show
ever if you don't know stage it stage it
dot com s-t-a-g-e-i-t dot com
we we do live shows uh every last
uh saturday of the month rob danson and
i were in a band it's called sunspin
it's just the two of us
just the two of us
we had the most biggest turnout and it
was the day after christmas i thought no
one was gonna show up
and thanks to all our followers and
everything
it was you know we've been able to make
this album and it's coming out and the
website's coming out soon we just got
the logo we did a photo shoot
socially distanced and uh we have we're
just really pumped it's in the mixing
stage now
then it's mastered and we should uh
start releasing songs
on itunes we'll have a pre-order for cds
we're gonna
release a song probably every week once
it comes out
and then the last week two two songs and
we're gonna release it that way on
itunes and then uh
have the album we've got amazing merch
when the merge comes out we've got like
this
collection lunchbox so it's a lunchbox
but includes all the merch
that it's a sun spin it's black with
yellow logo
sunspin it's badass so we're we're
pumped look
i don't expect to be a rockstar or
anything like that but i think we made
some great music and i think you're
gonna like it i hope that you share it
with all your friends
also the inside of you online store if
you go to it's on shopify but you go
inside of your online store
uh i'm gonna put another discount code
20 off for the uh for this coming
of a new year here that's gonna happen
soon and uh
we got some great stuff and i just put
on like uh put up some
lex luthor pictures and sorority boys
pictures and uh justice league pictures
and
along with uh tumblers and hats and and
towels and a bunch of stuff so there's
great merch and i'm gonna try and clear
it out
to get new merch for the next year so go
to inside of you online store
um and then uh the discount code will be
rosenbomb loves you
20. rosenbaum loves you 20.
why a all right let's uh let's get into
this wonderful guest merry christmas
happy new year happy new year ryan happy
new year
and uh i can't wait to hold you we're
just talking about taco night i was
starting taco nights here at my house
and ryan's like oh i just
saw an old email in march when you had
you cancelled the last it was sad
it was so sad i was just searching
through my email and then
oh god because it feels like it was
years ago i just can't yeah
it does feel like years ago i can't wait
to have organized softball with my
friends and
taco nights but you couldn't play
softball with us of course yeah you play
yeah you're good i'm very good yeah wow
i got i got a recline mvp on my shelf
somewhere
yeah all right let's get inside of a guy
that i've worked with who's a legend
you'll
if you if you don't know him he's got
some great stories he thought he was
going to be boring and i
i i love you clance and you're not
boring ever you're a genius and uh
it was an honor to interview you let's
get inside of clancy brown
it's my point of view you're listening
to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
you're so technologically advanced
you're really advanced in technology
clancy no look at you you're like
sitting behind the mic and
got the camera and everything you got
your you got your
barca lounger there it looks like yeah i
like to be comfortable
i'm naked from the waist down i uh yeah
that's how i roll i gotta roll you well
you look comfortable now look
because i could relate in a way that you
know when you play a villain or you're
you play some bad characters people oh
he's great and they start casting as the
bad guy right we all we get typecast
i've been typecast as either the
or the killer or the transvestite for a
while
yeah you know you're always right yeah
but is is there
i mean obviously i i bet you go through
stages right because you're
a seasoned actor you've been doing this
a long time was there a time where
you're like
no that i'm not doing the bad guy
anymore i'm i'm doing this or did you
kind of
was there a point you just said i just
want to work i love working
what kind of attitude you have well i
don't know i've always loved working
but you know it's that
you know you kind of want to do stuff
that you find interesting so
when you do a prison guard and they keep
asking you to do prison guards
it's like come on you know i don't want
to do a prison card
but that's you know that's what they
offer you so if
you know if you need to make the dough
you go to the prison guard if you don't
need to make the dough and you don't
mind auditioning then you'll you know
you
audition for something else audition for
the preacher and then they
then they decide that you're too uh and
they decide you're a preacher forever
that's happened a few times
well let me let me ask you this didn't
you ever feel like when your agent's
like hey they got this role
listen just hear me out clance this is a
prison guard you're like
don't you ever want to say there there's
not going to be a prison guard
or a prison guard movie or a prison
movie better than the one i
did no one's going to be but nothing's
better why would they want me as a
prison guard
in a movie that will never be as good as
shawshank redemption
who knows though right i mean if it's a
good part and it's a good script
that was such a great script it was like
you know everybody was like
we'll do anything in it so it's such a
good script that shawshank
but you know you you never know you you
read a good script and
you fall in love with the with the
script you fall in love with the
thing and then you see you know maybe
who's doing it and yeah
how expert they are and stuff like that
so you're logical
you're live logical
i you know i you know you try not to
repeat yourself and you try not to
but try not to jump to any conclusions
right yeah well look i either said if
you need if you need to if you're lucky
enough
you you go sign up for to do the thing
you did before because
you know you need to pay the kids
tuition or your mortgage or whatever
that's right that's right that's true
you don't think of those things till
later and you're like
you know i could do this and it's easy
and i've done this before i know what
they want i'll go in i'll do a good job
i'll try my best i'll make some money
and that's it
yeah yeah i mean yeah basically yeah
well let me ask you this so well you
jumped into shawshank because of the
prison thing but
i was just i rewatched it because i had
to because it's been a couple years and
it's one of the best movies ever made
period i mean is that something that
they offered you or you had to
read for that oh i read for it yeah yeah
i read for it's one of the worst
auditions i ever had
with frank and the casting director and
um casting director was
a young lady and she was dressed in this
nice really floral blouse and she
smelled good and she was done up
and and i had to scream
at her uh you know
you'll when i say you and
you'll piss when i say you piss you've
got that your mega dick mother i
i couldn't do it i couldn't do it
i couldn't do it like i couldn't get it
out and i apologized
to frank at the end of it i said i'm
sorry i did you you smell too good i
can't
i can't get this out
you know i can't yell at you this way
you're you're a nice young lady i can't
i just
i couldn't do it so i left there
thinking i'm never gonna be in this
movie
it's too bad it's such a good script and
i'll never be
so what happened so they called up and
they offered it to me they said yes now
you'll be all right you'll be good
i mean and on the flight outs i mean i
was convinced they had made a mistake
they thought i was somebody else and i
you know
they shot it in mansfield ohio so we're
flying into columbus or wherever we're
flying into which is it
which is a flight i've taken before
because that's where i'm from and
i'm sitting there and
back in the day when they flew your
first class i'm sitting there in first
class and i see
all these actors roll in you know all
these really good actors dave provol
and joe ranyo and uh and
uh you know just everybody that is there
gutting and
and uh and they see uh
i see uh bill sadler
and i'm like oh damn
that's that's who they think i am they
think i'm bill sadler and he's gonna be
playing my role
and so i just realized the whole flight
i was just like
in the window seat it's like this is
going to be so embarrassing when i get
there and they tell me that they're
going to send me home
i was absolutely convinced hang on
you're on this whole
three four five hour flight this you
swear to god this is what you're
thinking
you're thinking they're not they got the
wrong guy yeah oh yeah i mean not until
we sat down
and we read that we had a read through i
was convinced i mean you know
they had mark ralston and sadler and
i i mean they had like all these great
actors brian libby and
and i mean you know i'm trying to
come up with everybody's name they're
all guys that i recognize
and they're all character actors and
they're all terrific and i'm sitting
there going
i'm i'm not gonna this is not who they
think i'm somebody else
are you intimidated i wouldn't say i was
intimidated i knew i gave a bad
audition
i've had those the worst case scenarios
people always say i want offers i like
offers
but when you get an offer and then you
go in and then they're like
no that's not what we want but if you
audition for something and they like
what you did
then you do that most of the time right
so you go in there and you do something
that you're like well i barely even
got anything out i don't even know why
i'm here
yeah and then and then you get there and
then like what's what's your first day
like what's your first day as an actor
going i shouldn't even be here
no it was we went up for a rehearsal
back in the back that's back when they
were harshly rehearsed right so we so
we sat down and we had a read through
and there's morgan
and tim and you know all the guys and
gotten and whatnot
and we have the read through and it says
you know on your little thing it says
clancy brown
captain hadley so that's like when the
first time i thought
okay they that's
when i sit down they'll realize that
they think
somebody else is clancy brown you know
yeah not until it's not until i we
started reading it and
nobody seemed to blink an eye and i you
know it was the most intense
imposter syndrome i've ever had was that
jesus and then and then once we started
going it was fine you know it was okay i
mean i watched that scene on the rooftop
like it's you're so intense that even
years later i've seen this movie
everyone's seen it and then you watch it
again i really think you're going to
throw tim robbins off the roof
i really feel like you're losing your
but it's it's this contained
just
pure innate disdain for this man or any
of these people around you
and i'm like it's such a powerful
character
and you're thinking they're oh my god
prison's really
hard i bet they were like this and
prison sucks yeah
god i mean and he's stupid he's a stupid
stupid man i mean
he's just such a dumb man it's like
that's
those are the people that you're afraid
of most oh yeah authority that are so
deeply ignorant that they do stuff like
throw
people off roofs
what is wrong with that guy isn't that
the truth though well there are people
like that
around us that are just you're like wow
they just don't
see what we've seen and you hate to
think well what i say is right but then
you're saying well
this just this is just the right way
though am i missing something here
how does this guy think the opposite of
what i think so far
but i you know that's that's the way it
is you know what pisses me off is you've
played lex luthor longer than any other
lex luthor including me
do you know that that's an accident but
no no no you you played him more
consistently i'll bet you actually have
more hours of playing like sweetheart
i mean if we actually added up the time
what about crier how many episodes
did he do crier i think's only he's in
the second season oh
so he's way behind he's got he's got
time you win you we
we all know who likes luther no no no no
people
really i'm telling you you have a
following man you have a following
and people love you but it doesn't
matter i've said that before and people
are insulted when i say well let's say
you know well it's animation when i do
this no no no that role
means in as much as live action to
most people many people i understand
that i understand that
because i understand that because that's
sort of the
world that that superman was created
right
but but the live action adaptations
they're hard to do and smallville was
the best of them
oh come on yeah no no smallville was
definitely the best of them
uh you know lois and clark was kind of
fun for
for a minute you know because everybody
was young and good-looking
but it you know it became a soap opera
and nobody really cared after a while
but smallville
smallville was like the right show at
the right time
really realize real well i i think
smallville's just kind of
genius i didn't even know you watched it
yeah i saw a couple episodes sure
well really i'm not really the demo for
it but you know
you're not that much older than i am how
old are you i'm old i'm 61
60 what is the 20 yeah 20 20 i'm 61.
that's not old 59. how many times have
you thought to yourself clancy
i'm old and then you go what was i
thinking 10 years ago i wasn't old no
dude
but with this covet thing i've like
crossed into it
into the into the at-risk demo
i don't feel at risk well why are you at
risk do you have pre-existing
no no you know 60 60 plus right
and that's what they say 60 plus but you
feel healthy you look good
thank you so do you my man well thanks
man i got this thing if you notice this
big thing on my face it's not a fight
i'm not that tough but uh
it was just a little pre-cancer thing
they burned off no big deal
i always feel like i need to say you
know when you have something on your
face you got to go oh
this is that or really yeah i mean you
know what i mean
you had a little skin cancer yeah have
you ever dealt with any of that stuff
no not yet knock on wood not gonna worry
yeah fair people although i've been
bitching at my dad for
i don't know how many years he's 68 and
uh
he's you know balding and he just has
moles and he never wears sun protection
and he's
bathes in the sun and he's never had
skin cancer not gonna want anything and
i'm like
i'm always telling him and then who gets
skin cancer this this
where does he live he lives in new york
well he just got a place in the
caribbean to get this little apartment
then he's going to be in there he's got
to use he's got to use
sunscreen down there man because it's
it's about being exposed to the sun
in new york you know he's walking around
the building there's no sun in new york
that's true that's very true
you know what amazes me it's hollywood
and
you look at all the divorces and all the
and i look and i'm like you're
married to the same woman since 90
freaking three
yeah i'm lazy
is that what it is yeah because i'm just
so
i'm just a lazy old man that yeah
i actually i actually got we actually
got married
um the day or yeah the day after i guess
well the day after no it must not have
been the day after but the day after we
shot that
um roof scene in uh
shawshank i took off and went to chicago
and then got married the next day and
then brought my bride back
and to uh to mansfield ohio
for the honeymoon and to finish filming
by the way were you did you are you one
of those actors who kind of gets into
the role where you were
you're sort of like an off
camera until the roll's over or your
method
no i don't think so i mean maybe i am
i'm going to ask your wife
i'm interviewing your wife yeah does she
read lines with you ever
uh no i i do wrangle my kids sometimes
to do that
really but not my wife yeah well who ran
lines with you for like like a shawshank
movie or highlander or any of these
movies
uh well let's see we at uh shawshank
uh i rented a house with larry
brandenburg
who played skeet and he's
uh we rented this uh farmhouse
he's from rural minnesota rural
minnesota and i'm from
rural ohio so we were quite comfortable
there in
in mansfield outside mansfield we rented
a house outside loudounville
and so we you know we were just hanging
out watching uh satellite tv when
satellite tv went
with a big freaking satellite yeah big
box and all that stuff on your desk so
we
you know we we're just hanging out right
there and then i brought my bride back
and he
fo'd for for a week or so so you can
make
sweet hot newly married love that's
right baby
the days when you used to make love in
the corn fields you know
oh my god hey are you one of the
questions are you one of those guys that
the director wants you to just go
bigger and bigger and bigger or they
have to bring you down
depends i appreciate that direction
like go bigger bring it down you know
whatever uh
the story i tell of shawshank is that uh
frank frank gave me
one of my favorite directions of all
time which uh
we had we had a group of guys there that
were
that were really uh better than their
their roles you know any one of those
guys could have been
uh should have been leaving their own tv
show they're they're all very good but
because of the script was so good we all
wanted to do it so
so we were always thinking of stuff to
to
steal screen time with right we were
always thinking up stuff to fill out our
characters and to to you know make more
noise for ourselves on camera
and uh i was no exception and i there
was one
shot where i'm walking across the yard
and i decided okay my guy
is his brain is rotting because he's so
dumb
and uh and he's he's getting his
tourettes
and so he just starts swearing yeah for
no reason and so i'm walking across the
thing and i'm just swearing to myself
and and yeah i can't even remember what
i made up but i made up some
silly stuff that just had no no relation
to anything just
total non-sequiturs and i'm walking
across there and we're rolling and
you know it's a big shot that they're
setting up and you know
big cranes and lots of extras and
and doing it and
and we rehearse it one time rehearse it
a couple of times i'm
working out what i'm going to say and
finally we roll
and i do it and then you know everything
stops and they say hey clance just a
second uh frank's going to come down and
give you some notes and frank like
climbs off the
top of the roof and chopping it off the
crane and he comes down he puts his arm
around me and walks down he's got his
little cigarette
walking along and he says you know that
thing that you're doing that that that
that that swearing that sort of tourette
see thing that you're doing is your walk
and i said yeah man how about that huh
it's pretty good right good little
action i think the character is okay he
says no no don't do that it looks stupid
so he couldn't tell you that he couldn't
tell you that from afar
and say hey just don't talk yeah but how
great that he didn't
embarrass me that way right i mean you
know he like climbed down
and he put his arm around me and he said
don't do that it really looks stupid
all right i love you frank you can
direct me doing anything
who is the most fun working with on that
on that project i mean everybody around
you it seemed like everybody was great
we all had fun yeah
that was when uh you know when we
i guess when we first started
when was it it was uh we worked from
we worked from what how was it labored
now it wasn't labor day we worked until
labor day worked like from july 4th to
labor day
and anyway there was basketball playoffs
going on
and it was during um
like 93 or something was that the knicks
yeah
nicks and bulls were playing so you had
a bunch of guys
from chicago and you had a bunch of guys
from new york
uh in the cast right and and so we'd all
go down to you know
the local uh you know buffalo wild wings
or whatever they had there
we'd watch the game and uh and that was
our social life
so but you know we were all having fun
we were all figuring out there was a
couple of restaurants in mansfield ohio
we all got a kick out of the fact that
it was it was
voted in one of these magazines as
one of the worst cities in the united
states because of the poverty and
crime and stuff but we never really
experienced that they were all really
great to us
yeah how how tall are you six three how
tall are you i'm
six on the dot you know a lot of people
will say you're a shorter legs loser i'm
a shorter lex luthor
for sure do you think people since
you're like a big guy you look
intimidating you can kick someone's ass
maybe you probably can do you think
people people
at a young age were you always tall did
you get picked on at a young age or did
you
get it to a certain age where people
started messing with you because you
were bigger or what would you go through
as a as a kid
yeah a little bit of everything i didn't
really get into my body until i was
in high school and college you know i
guess i got a little bit of
a little bit of every reaction popular
were you popular
are they popular you love them yeah i i
i never perceived it that way although i
ran into a
guy who was a couple years behind me in
high school and his daughter
was he was also looking for a place to
send his daughter daughter to
high school and so we you know renewed
our acquaintance
when i knew him he was kind of small
kind of a
you know maybe a hundred pounds soaking
wet uh
and uh and i was a senior in high school
and when i met him he was
bigger than me he was six five he was
you know two whatever
100 pounds and smart as a whip like he
always was
and uh you know he said oh you were the
dude in high school
you know you were the you were the one
everybody looked up to and i never
perceived that
when i when i was in high school you
never saw that in yourself
yeah hell no well now was it because you
were humble or were you were you uh
a nervous kid were you an anxious kid
anything like that yeah
i wouldn't say necessarily i mean
kind of dumb come on a dumb i'm a dumb
kid
i don't believe that see that's what i
always said about myself and i'm
stopping you know i try to stop myself
from saying that but
i was like yeah i wasn't very smart my
dad you know he was always really smart
and i think he was just like i got
a dumb kid and
you know that's it and it's just like
not i'm telling you
for a long time i felt all those things
and then i was like wait a minute you
weren't dumb
and then you know you know through
therapy they're like well don't you
learn all these lines don't you
do this don't you do you think dumb
people that's what they could do so you
start to
so you don't honestly believe you're
dumb back then or
well not now i mean you know what do you
back then all you're doing is comparing
yourself to
those around you right yeah you know
they were better athletes there were
smarter kids there were you know
you're yeah i was never the smartest and
i was never the best athlete and so you
know you don't think that you're
anything special
that's the way looking at it were your
parents like i love you clance i love
you i'll always love you
i'm rooting for you you're a smart kid
you're a great athlete or were they kind
of like i don't give a
yeah you know it was the 70s my parents
were busy with other stuff
you know they were busy with other
things
you know my mom and dad always say to me
you were such a
such a better parent than we ever were
why do they say that because you're more
attentive you're more
present no it's just you know it's just
a different time you know they were
they were we were in dc and my dad was
in congress and they had
important stuff to do and think about
and
they didn't they didn't really pay that
much attention to their kids you know it
was a different time you didn't have to
you didn't you didn't have to be a
helicopter parent back in the day they
were
you know involved with the school and on
the parent council and you know all that
other crap but you know
they didn't really they didn't really
monitor me or anything
right but they were supportive right
they said clancy and proud
yeah they came to the shows and the
games you know
the shows yeah when was the first show
when did you start like uh i'm gonna be
an actor
when was that moment oh well i i don't
know you know
after college i just thought i'd give it
a shot you know i always liked doing it
um and they supported it i did it yeah
yeah they i you know i did it in high
school and
college and stuff they didn't come out
to the college shows so much but they
did you know
we came to the high school shows and all
that stuff i mean yeah well were they
like at the end of the show was your dad
uh
was he like you know clancy huh you're a
pretty damn good actor
that was pretty good no didn't get that
no
no they were they were they were
supportive i mean my dad said my dad was
particularly supportive he just said
look you know
i i work hard to give my kids
the opportunity to do whatever they want
so if you want to go try this that's
fine
that's nice though that was at after
college my mom was not
that way she was like you know your dad
worked hard to give you
this this opportunity of the family
business or this opportunity to go into
politics and you're
throwing it all away to go be an actor
and i was like hey that's not what dad
said
right because there was a newspaper in
your family like people
they ran a newspaper there was a
congress that was a did that a
congressman
yeah congressman so you had all these
things these aspirations as a
congressman run a newspaper do it
i'm gonna be an actor yeah i mean yeah
but you know what it's what my dad said
he's like
you know yeah i this is what i did this
is what i do
you know i followed in my father's
footsteps my father
my father says that you know my his my
grandfather was a congressman
he ran newspapers and stuff but he said
there's no reason why you have to do
that
you know you should go do what you want
to do that's why we that's why
you know parents parents do what they do
is to give you the opportunity to do it
now i you know did he think it was going
to work out i'm sure he didn't
that's that's not something parents
think is gonna work out you know
you know i promised him that i would
just try it for a few years and then you
know
go to grad school or whatever well what
was the first time
that you're like ah i got them they're
they're really proud i could tell
they're proud
you did something something clicked
where they're like oh he's successful
this is happening
i don't know i think you know when they
it's with with every parent is when your
kid
is praised by someone
else to you you know
like when somebody says you know you're
but i wasn't there for that
you know when i hear that my daughter is
a brilliant director
then i'm i'm so proud of her you know
that's those are the those are the great
times that's why
that's when the worry goes away i'm sure
that's what happened with my folks is
that
you know one of their friends said i saw
your son in this and it was really good
maybe shawshank maybe shawshank they
thought that was it but
you know i don't know i was also getting
married then so that probably wasn't the
first thing
right right right they wanted they
wanted you to get married that's what
it's like when are you gonna get married
yeah
always why is that my grandmother still
she's 92 she's like
when are you gonna you'd be such a good
dad why don't you want to do this i'm
like first of all you're 92. how long am
i gonna i'm
am i gonna have a kid for you so you
could see him for two years you know
you're 92.
i have to live with this woman for the
rest of my life i have to have this
child and take care of it i go well my
grandma told me to do it but she's dead
now
you should you should have a child you
would be a good dad
change your life how does it change your
life how does it change your life
honestly
uh it makes you well you know okay we're
actors
so we spend a lot of time inside our own
heads
and and worrying about um
you know about our auditions worrying
about our
how we present to the world how we
present to maybe a specific person or a
specific thing
and um and suddenly
you have to get out of that and you have
to take care of something so that it
doesn't die
you have to make sure something in your
life doesn't die
while you're well you're responsible for
it
and so that just kind of changes your
life there for a minute you have to stop
thinking about yourself
that's terrifying too at the same time
yeah sure it is
sure it is but i mean here's the other
thing like
you know less fortunate less
privilege less you know that's
intelligent people have done it just
fine
for many generations is that what you
kept telling yourself
less comfortable people have done have
gotten by just fine
inside of you is brought to you by met
pro this is a company that i like
because
it's all about health it's all about
changing it's all about
uh science and uh we all want to improve
our health
i know i do and where do you freaking
start
every day you're like oh you know and
then you're like what does it matter i
don't even
let me do my arms today
i'm gonna go for a walk with thousands
of health strategies available
identifying which one works for your
body is difficult and that's the key
because you could sit here and go oh i
was doing this one thing and it worked
for me everybody's different
i've done things that people told me to
do like this this stinks man i don't
want any part of this
according to met pro m-e-t-p-r-o that is
the key to seeing results is to master
your metabolism at metpro your
metabolism
isn't some mystery it's a data point
armed with hard science
met pro is your health concierge
delivering one-on-one coaching
personalized nutrition and fitness
regimens
metpro's coaches provide busy
professional athletes weekend warriors
and everyone in between with the support
and education they need to live a
healthier
life folks if you're looking for a high
touch experience
working with a metabolic expert or if
you want access to the tools
their industry leading coaches use visit
met pro dot co
slash inside that's visit
met pro m-e-t-p-r-o dot c-o
slash inside you take their assessment
it's easy
you speak with their team to learn which
option is best for you
and listeners you'll also get up to one
month free when you sign up you gotta
try this
head to metpro.co
inside to take advantage of this
opportunity inside of you is brought to
you by petsmart
i'll tell you my dog irv he's a shepherd
mix and bland she's like a
rot poodle lab you know all over the
place
these two dogs have gotten me through
this pandemic
i mean they have really helped me i mean
cuddling
walking taking my mind off things
and uh you know i don't know what i do
without him because i don't have a
significant other you do ryan and uh
it's important but
um you know when you love your animals
that much you got to give back and you
have to you know there's so many things
to do with
with an animal that you know that is a
bit of a pain
and uh petsmart really makes it easier
for us all from the beginning of the
pandemic petsmart has been an essential
retailer making sure you can get
everything your pet needs
right when you need it at over 1600
convenient locations
they lead the pack with safe and easy
ways to shop and i like the word
safe and i like the word easy petsmart
has responded to the unprecedented
demand for contactless shopping by
adding curbside pickup for website or
app
orders and now petsmart offers free
same-day delivery powered by doordash
through january 31st
2021 so you can get everything your pet
needs right to your door and right when
you need it
so be smart be better than smart
be petsmart check out petsmart.com
for more details i mean i envy people
like you because i look at you you give
i'm sure you'll sit here and say you're
wrong i'm not but you seem just together
you've always been sort of like you
don't really care about the limelight
you don't you're kind of a private guy
you're just you know you like acting you
love your family and that's it is that
is that
pretty right on yeah
yeah i mean even again i mean that's
pretty much it yeah
yeah i i don't know i think that you're
just your whole disposition the the way
you handle yourself
you can handle these things that come at
you but i wonder my question is
in the beginning did you feel that
anxiety did you feel like oh my god i'm
oh am i gonna have a kid i have what am
i gonna do
what am i gonna i'm gonna fail he's
gonna it's gonna be my fault did you
ever go through any of that
yeah i mean you know with the kid you
get yeah you
you suddenly have to think about things
you never had to think about before
you know i mean you you you know you
suddenly have to think you know i i got
to keep a roof over this head i got to
make this mortgage i mean that's sort of
when i started
sort of when i started doing everything
the blessing was it's when i started
doing voiceover
right and that was just a revelation
that was so much fun and
i'm so glad that that happened um but i
you know i did that kind of to stay in
town not that
not to solve any of my problems i just
did it because i wanted to
i didn't want to have to leave town to
work which is where i always had to go
but um it was always
you know i was always nervous about
keeping the roof over the head
and doing and you know balancing that
with
being present i wanted to be present as
well there was a period when i was like
probably
over charging for my services that
took a little while for me to realize
that wait a minute they
don't do that anymore they don't overpay
for actors anymore
yeah they certainly do right when right
when the corporations decided that
top of show is the minimum right yeah
and your quotes don't matter and all the
rest of that stuff so i think i hit a i
think i hit a high quote right when my
daughter was born right after shawshank
you know
um i think that was my highest quote and
then
after that it was you know a couple
years of not
getting paid that and realizing okay i
have to
i have to work i have to work for less
you know
what was the you know obviously people
always come up to me and they're like oh
my god clancy brown when you guys
switched
uh switched minds and the guy that was a
good one that was a good thing
yeah that was a good one the great brain
robbery
that was a good episode it wasn't i
never i don't think i ever really worked
with you and all of a sudden you're
sitting there with me and we're just
going back and forth and you're like say
your line and then you say it like me
but in your what you know what i mean
oh it was so fun it was so fun it was i
remember us laughing going with that it
was kind of confusing it was in a way
but it was really
fun and having andrea romano who we both
adore right right directing us yeah
but you know how how fun is that too
that they wrote it
and who wrote that one by the way do you
remember i don't remember who
who wrote that one yeah it wasn't bruce
you know how fun that they took those
characters and decided to do that
and let us do that you know we're
looking for a way to knew that we would
like it knew that we could
pull it off and have so much fun doing
it yeah
because they could have done it with
anybody they could have done it with any
bad guy in any
any superhero but you know i
take that as a big compliment it was the
play i was playing lex luthor on
smallville
you were the voice of lex i was voicing
the flash in the justice league
and then we switched then we switched
and it was just all this
yeah it was great it was really great
you know you've worked with so many
people
what's the most fun you've had besides
obviously working with me but like
like big actors like what's the one guy
actually like wow he's doing voiceovers
too because a lot of
big big actors do them right i've not
found that like
uh that people that are well known for
film and television that they're
actually that
good i think the people probably the
people we had in justice league
were the most versatile of that crew
that like crossed
across platforms easily you know
you and lumley and uh
you know lamar all those guys yeah maria
and susan yeah georgia but i what i've
usually found with stunt casting is that
they're not that good you know they're
they're a little
they're a little um intimidated by the
technology divided by the process of it
and they and they're not
they're not good at it but you know what
it is they don't
let go as much and they just i think
when you're
when you're doing it when you i found
that the more i just said it and
just let go and
andrew said do another one like this you
just do it don't worry about looking
like an idiot just do it it's just the
voice you just have to get something no
matter how you get there
and i i definitely could tell when i was
working with bigger actors you know that
they just hadn't done it and that wasn't
their passion and you know they're like
and so it was harder to get out of them
you'd assume
it's just yeah they're not used to doing
that's really what it is not that
they're not good at it just that they're
not familiar with
it the guy that i that that was really
good at it from the get-go
was a guy that i got in to spongebob uh
dennis quaid and i just worked with
dennis on uh
on a movie i can't remember which one
not dreamscape no
no no no i've worked with them on uh
i've worked with them on a couple things
it was one called the express
and one called uh
at any price it must have been after the
express and i
i said uh i said to i think it was
andrea that was actually doing spongebob
at that point
and i said to andre i said we've got to
get got to get uh
dennis in here because all he does is
his version of mr krabs all the time all
he's doing he just
he just loves to you know be mr grabs in
front of me and we
you know wait a minute dennis quaid
impersonates you from shawshank no no he
impersonates me doing mr crab
i'm miss krabs right right right so is
he dead on
uh no he sounds like dennis doing mr
krabs so
they thought up they thought of the
episode uh grandpappy the pirate
and so mr krabs grandpappy was coming
into town and
and he had to and mr krabs had to put on
a show that he was a pirate that you
know the krusty krab was actually a
pirate ship and not a
you know he was following in his his
footsteps and
and so he put on this fake show and they
and the boys were my crew and all the
rest of that stuff and
dennis came in and just knocked it out
of the park man he was having so much
fun
and he brought in his son and he was
just like hey
wow he came in and nailed it he was
he's he's a pretty free spirit that do
you still talk to dennis he gets going
uh not as much as i'd like to i like him
so much he's a good guy you know
i don't know him i i've never met him
but i've always loved him i always loved
his work
it was like him and michael keaton in
the 80s i love those guys
they just had an energy to him you know
what i mean yeah and now he's doing that
commercial now
yeah i just don't get it but you know
what i'm sure it's commercial it's just
odd
it's just odd i just did this quick yeah
it's just it's it's like that
and look i would like i respect people
want to make money they get to do
whatever it was just an odd commercial
you know it's like that one uh what's
his name um with the
tom selleck it's it's it i i don't it's
a he's humble but it's
five minutes long oh that one's a little
longer i changed the channel i come back
after lunch it's still going on
i don't know what the hell it is but you
know commercial yeah it's an info yeah
but
how do they your infomercials all day
you gotta get that money out of the old
people we gotta we gotta
is that what it is yeah gotta get money
out of old people
do you think you'll be uh the kind of
actor do you feel like you you
are you one that just loves acting so
much that you'll work until you die
or you'll retire one day and say it
i'm done uh yeah
i'll retire one day yeah you just won't
want to do anything
no i mean you know but we got this
voiceover gig man we can we can
we can always we can always do something
you know obviously you just did this
movie
mortuary collection collection the
mortuary collection
now look i love horror movies okay i'm a
big horror movie fanatic
and this is a poster you're the cover
you're the guy you're the mortuary
collector
me and caitlin yeah right you ain't
location
you're the mortician now look i love
i love horror movies and right now i
mean i mean look i probably watch
one a day i have i have shutter shutter
account which is so good
more to our collection the premiere is
on shutter and by the way yes it
premieres on shutter and i love
shutter just because it's 5.99 a month
and i have just
a thousand movies to choose from of
course
i'm going to choose the mortuary
collection by the way yeah and uh
spindel ryan spindell directed it
yeah you're gonna love it i mean i
already saw it i already watched it
did you see they sent me a link i love
the way it's shot i
love the creepiness of all i love those
angles and i love the end the twist
look i don't want to give anything away
but like i just love how they usually
these write-ups these log lines are
usually
but this is a good log line usually it's
like two brothers kill their parents
okay well he told the story this is on
the cusp of retirement an eccentric
mortician recounts several of the
strangest stories he's encountered in
his long career
things take a turn for the
phantasmagorical when he learns that the
final story
is his own mortuary collection
it's not completely accurate well
retirement is it retirement well uh
is that what well there's the twist
there's that you find out that it's not
really as retirement as
i don't want to give away fate let's say
right right right
right but uh i think is it good that
ryan is ryan is uh
you know he's a he's a born storyteller
he's uh and he loves the
medium and he's he knows his way around
a set and a camera
and uh you know he's he's a talent he's
a real real talent i
compare him to like a young spielberg
young jj abrams
he's like in that in that mold where he
is
you know he knows well it creates a
world a unique
world an inviting kind of scary world
like a function like think it up and put
it on screen
and whatever problem comes up he can
he can work around and solve
and make it conform to his vision and
his vision is terrific his vision is
real specific
and real detailed and and uh you know he
took
it took two years to make that and
longer than that if you count
the short that he did before which is
called the babysitter murder
right uh which was the kind of the proof
of concept
thing that he that he made and
so it's you know i guess you could say
it's been seven years
everybody has these long periods but he
said look you know
we we couldn't make it quickly
for the amount of money that they wanted
to do it what we had to do was
make it we had to make it
well slowly you know we had to do it
we had to do it the way we wanted to do
it but that meant we had to take our
time
you know they had to stretch the dollars
through the through this two-year period
and so you know he's
he's good at it and he doesn't he didn't
compromise that much you know he
he or he knew where to compromise that
it wouldn't
it wouldn't look bad i think it's
gorgeous it's a good
it really is i was surprised by how well
it looked
this is it just it is it's cinematic
it's absolutely cinematic
when you watch it and the angles on your
face i'm like thinking of all the
prosthetics like what the hell was he
did they cgi essays because it looks it
was it was practicals right it was
prosthetics
yeah yeah how many hours were you in the
makeup trailer
not not too many i mean we had we had
one uh moe mine heart was the
key there she it was it was about
three hours i would say and it would
have been faster if she
if she had a partner and every now and
then we could
there was another uh makeup artist that
would assist her but
that makeup artist was also responsible
for everybody else so
right you know a lot of times it was
just so like you know we
range from like two and a half to three
and a half hours
you got cranky come on admit it you'd
get cranky you had to
no it didn't not with her not at all not
with her
you know after after three hours in a
minute you look her up on imdb she's
gorgeous she's
she's beautiful she's funny and we you
know we you know we
i i know the drill and she knows the
drill are you trying to hook me up with
your makeup artist is that what you're
trying to do yeah there you go
there you go hey let me ask you look i
mean you do so many fun things i look at
all the projects with the animation you
get a happy family i mean it could be
lying it could be miserable there it
could be just like hell at your house
but
you know life's good for you you're not
old you're 61 you make it sound like
you're old
you're not you're not i'll tell you
right now yeah definitely not
[Music]
dude but you also like have legendary
roles like highlander which i know you
talk about ad nauseam and like starship
troopers and like
i mean these movies when you do them i
mean obviously when you're working with
sean connery and highlander you're like
sean connery's and it's gonna be a big
movie right
you thought that yeah that movie is a
complete accident
yeah i don't know if you i don't know if
you know anything about that movie i
don't know but the guy
the guy that wrote it greg wyden he was
a
he was a college kid he was i think he
was an undergrad
you know usc or ucla or wherever the
hell he was and that was his
he wrote this script as his final for
some
cinema script writing class that he did
and
uh and then these uh these
these buzzards these scavengers uh
that were the producers as
these two guys who's i won't mention
their names they
they sort of like take over they sort of
pick over these things and they go in
and they snag a script that's
you know maybe won an award or you know
got an a or whatever it is and they and
they pay the guy
you know five hundred dollars just five
hundred dollars for your script area
and then they and then they go and they
pitch it
to the wherever they had the deal and uh
and i think they said they would pay you
know they paid him a couple thousand
bucks and
a portion of the of the budget
if if uh you know a percentage of the
budget if it gets
if it gets made if it gets picked up in
may and this became high
yeah and they're low budget guys so they
you know they're thinking they're going
to pay them
maybe another 10 grand or something so
then
uh they as these producers do they just
go out to big stars anyway you know they
expecting to get turned down and so they
went to
they went to sean connery and said hey
we want you to play the highlander i
don't even think they even
read the script they just said you know
highlander uh
that's a scottish man so let's go to the
big scottish uh
scott movie star so they sent it to him
and he said no
he said no i'm not interested in doing
that but i would be interested in
playing
ramirez and so suddenly they had
interest from
sean connery and the budget goes up and
then they said well if we can get him to
play ramirez let's
let's go get you know let's get somebody
who are we going to get to play the
highlander and they
you know they start casting around
somebody says well you know you should
send it out to this uh this young french
actor who just won the cesar for his
role in subway and you know he's
he's a he's a big european star so
they sent it out to kristoff and he said
oh sean connery's in it i'll do it
so it's something they had the big
european star the biggest european star
at the time
at the time the budget goes up yeah the
budget goes up again
and so then they go out to uh arnold
schwarzenegger because he had just done
uh uh terminator and they said
we're gonna get arnold schwarzenegger
the president couldn't go up again
arnold schwarzenegger said nah i
i i don't want to play a bad guy again i
don't want to play a bad guy
i want to play so the budget goes down
like oh no what are we going to do what
are we going to do and
the director they got uh
they got a director out of australia who
had
basically made his bones doing music
videos named russell mulcahy
although he had directed a really
terrific uh
movie called razorback which is kind of
like jaws in the outback
in in australia and they got him
for probably not much money but he's but
really talented guy
and uh and so russell was like
hanging out with his music video friends
and he talks to
he was talking to sting and they're like
yeah we you know
russell said we went out to i don't know
who we're gonna get we went out to
schwarzenegger he turned us down and
things said well i just worked with this
big uh
this big american bloke named clancy
brown
on this movie called the bride you know
he's he seems like a pretty good actor
he's like a pretty good guy i want you
to
check out him so i met with the
he calls up the producer said check out
this other guy this clancy bryant guy
and
i met with those guys i'm like
i i think it's a great story yeah i
would love to play it but you know how
much you're going to pay me and they
don't pay me they don't want to pay me
anything
and i don't have a quote or anything but
rich of anything so they pay me nothing
and they're thrilled because they pay me
nothing they get their
they get their movie made and we go and
we make the movie
and greg is you know he's this kid out
of college who wrote this thing and
suddenly he's a millionaire because he
gets a
percentage of a real budget and
and his career is launched right after
that
so this random act of yeah we'll give
you a couple of thousand dollars second
choice
if the budget goes up you'll get a
percentage it's one in a million it's
like winning the lottery you're most
likely it's never gonna get made you're
gonna make zero money and the guy
becomes a millionaire takes his career
off
right there's a bunch of people that won
the lottery they paid sean a ton of
dough and you know
i think it made kristoff a big star
and uh and he got a lot of money i got
nothing
i got i got no money you got residuals
yeah no no didn't get residuals because
it was under a basket contract
oh my god and you're like a major
character
i mean come on yeah oh the son of a bees
that's okay i mean you know it was it
was fun to do i didn't want to do any
more after that anyway so
you know those producers were not fun to
work for yeah it sounds like you went
through hell
you probably did that stunt at the end
when you felt 10 stories they probably
made you do that for nothing
yeah put me in the rig and did a fan
descender
hey real quick you made some good
friends made some good friends on it
yeah who's your closest uh celebrity
friend who's your like the one friend
that you still
because you you have one guy who
happened it's me you're my best
celebrity friend
i bet you don't hang out with a lot of
celebrities no i don't i don't really
know any celebrities
you never hung out with tim robbins or
morgan freeman after shawshank you never
hung out always happy to see them
i don't think morgan recognizes me
anymore but
uh yeah always happy to see tim i saw
tim recently
his son had done a film and it was at
the
austin austin film festival i saw him
so it's good to see him he's he's i play
ice hockey without it
he's always down at actors gang got
something always doing something down
there at that field he's really sweet
he's just so soft-spoken has he always
been so soft-spoken
yeah yeah it's just this guy you know
just hey man how you doing this all
right
all right this has been incredible and i
hope you had fun this is real quick my
patreons who
are amazing they support the podcast
it's called talking with clancy
brown this is rapid fire so you just
answer them
steph a is there a character you've
always wanted to voice but never got the
chance to voice
a character that i've always wanted i
don't know the next one i don't know
i don't know there's got to be a
character we're not thinking of what if
there was a character like
they're doing a shining video game and
they want jack nicholson voice but
someone to play jack
there you go yeah this is another
question emily s what's been your
favorite role to perform i'm guessing
you're going to say all of them
no not all of them not all of them
uh i i really like that i really like
this montgomery dark guy
montgomery dart mortuary collector he's
yeah yeah the mortgage collection he is
he's a he's a fun fun character he's a
fun dude
yeah you uh chomped up uh ate some
scenery let's just
say yeah we were going crazy just
like certain looks at the door when
you're looking out there and the angles
and then the
your eyes as the door is closing just
like that i was like oh yeah he's
enjoying this man
yeah chewing it up danny amazing guest
loves clancy brown
any stories from buckaroo bonsai did he
realize it was going to be one of the
all-time great cult films um
no didn't realize it was gonna be
all-time great cult film
but it is kind of the bar for me it's
like it
it was maybe my was my first movie
i think it might have been my first
movie after i moved out to
los angeles and uh and i read the script
and i had
no idea what was going on but it was so
much fun to read
uh the the the whole
the whole time of that shoot i was just
laughing and giggling and just
you know i i got this imposter complex
anyway
and there i am with you know goldblum
and and
peter and lithgow and all these guys so
i'm you know i
just the luckiest guy on earth i think
what am i doing here
i have no idea pepe cerna for crying out
loud you know
what am i doing here and uh my favorite
moment of that
was we're shooting a scene in a bus
and peter and ellen barkin are having
this intense conversation in the front
and all the hong kong cavaliers are kind
of in the back of the bus
and um jeff kind of leans out in the
middle in the into the aisle and he
looks at me and he goes come here
just just watch me doing this the whole
time and he leans out into the aisle and
he's doing this little rope trick
and rawhide is just is my character is
just like
completely focused on this rope trick
that he's doing and he starts doing that
and finally richter
the director says jeff stop doing that
clancy stop doing that
and he says what what we're just we're
just you know livening up the background
here we're just
we're just showing you know just having
a you know character life
and he says you're pulling too much
focus and he just like looks at me and
waits because
i don't know what you're talking about
jeff
was the king of pulling focus at with no
effort at all he pulls all the focus
uh there was the start of a great
friendship between him and peter and
stuff
but i've always gotten a big kick at it
that's awesome
jeff and i used to do this routine he he
picked on me because i was so dumb
he or included me because i was so dumb
he would say uh he would say um
just uh i'm gonna go up to the the prop
master and i'm gonna
ask him a question i'm gonna turn to you
and i'm gonna say a bunch of nonsense
but before i say nonsense i'm gonna say
maha and then you say yaha
and then and then i'll say a bunch of
nonsense and you repeat that nonsense
back to me and then i'll talk to you
so i had no idea what he was doing but
what
of course anybody that knows anything is
that maha yaha
is the is the three stooges uh routine
that mo and uh curly did after curly had
his stroke
he would say you would he would say he
would ask
a question of somebody larry or whatever
and he would turn to curly and say maha
and ma and curly stroked out curly we go
huh he would come back again
and and curly we got
and then he would turn back and he would
answer the question for somebody else so
we did this routine
all throughout the shoot and it was only
at the end that i realized that it was a
three stooges routine
goldblum goldblum is such a blast see
everybody
the thing it's amazing because i always
i
had so much fun i did this one movie and
it bombed it became sort of a cult and
it was the most fun i ever had on in the
movie like that's what i always wanted
to do so those
those are the moments where it's just
like you're enjoying you're like this is
why i'm here
and it'd be icing on the cake if it was
uh if it was a hit but it wasn't
maya p says are there any roles you've
done that you wish had gone longer or
hope to play again one day
uh that one the buckaroo bonsai for sure
um you know that one
and maybe this we'll see maybe
montgomery dark we'll see if that even
happens i'm not sure i could see it's
cool anthology can keep going you know
go to hey let me ask you this are you
still doing the flash the series
no i haven't done that in a while when
was the last time you did that
a couple years ago i think it was the
gorilla garage
when gorilla grodd took over eileen and
i hadn't done it since
did you like it did you like your
experience on the flash yeah it was it
was
you know that was an interesting thing
when i first did it it hadn't aired yet
and so it wasn't kind of
it wasn't anything yet and everybody was
you know
working hard and really nervous and all
the rest of that stuff and then
when i went up and did it again it had
aired and it was a big hit
and you know suddenly everybody was sort
of more into their social media and
their
and their appointments and all the rest
of that stuff and so yeah it wasn't as
much fun it was
it was a different set success makes it
a different place
you know there was a different vibe to
it yeah it's still a good show
i think it's still a good show but yeah
it was a different button you know had
you know you had to
it had to be more enjoyable to work in
the you know
70s 80s even the 90s before all the
phones and everything
not just age us but like there's a
certain simplicity and also uh an is
more intimate where
you didn't have anything to do but be
together and talk and experience life
together i think that now everybody's so
distracted
do you do you feel that when you're on
sets today where it's not as present
people aren't present people aren't
it's not as fun yeah i i i i don't know
if i go it's different you know for sure
um you know
dq used to talk about dennis used to
say you know we had so much fun on uh on
long riders we were all hanging out
together and
it says you know when nobody hangs out
anymore uh
we were talking about this as we were
hanging out in some bar
you know we were actually socializing
right
but uh you know lamenting that a couple
of old guys going hey
nobody's friendly anymore nobody hates
you anymore
you know but uh so i guess i guess
that's something but it's just
it's just different now you know people
people go to their
their caves a little quicker right you
know we
we also we also socialize you know
i did this uh a season of this thing
called emergence last
year and we hung out you know
allison tolman and and and everybody we
sort of we sort of
powered around a bit i love it well hey
this has been awesome
did you have fun yeah did you have fun
yeah man you're easy to talk to
my turtle i love the turtle where how
long have you had the turtle curtain
i don't know they're not making them
anymore it's from this uh uh woolen mill
called fairball william mills and they
would have the
they had this uh native american uh
collection that they would do and that's
from that i love that
i love that thing all right dude much
love i love this i'm gonna i'm gonna
harass you because we're gonna hang out
when this is over
all right fair enough all right i'll see
you later thanks again man
all right thanks ben he's a family guy
he's a private guy and it was hard to
get him
in the studio well he didn't come in the
studio we zoomed but it was hard to get
him to zoom
yeah and uh just hearing the stories
when he's like they're gonna fire me i
think they got the wrong guy for uh
shawshank redemption and things like
that and it's how i always feel like up
they're gonna hear me in the table read
they're gonna fire me up so i'm not
fired yet
they're gonna watch me and i'm ugly and
they're gonna you always think these
things
and he thought that the entire way
through the the shooting the movie and
he's working with these geniuses
i like i like that he got married the
day after that rooftop scene i thought
that was a fun time oh yeah
after he was so mean to our friend tim
robinson he was so mean he almost threw
him off a roof and then the next day
he exchanged vows at the love of his
life ah man
i remember the first day when andy came
into shawshank
well i i think let me let me try to get
it i remember the first day
andy dufresne came into shawshank
is that better i'm gonna close my eyes
and not look at you
let me see here i remember the first day
when andy dufresne came into shawshank
that's good not bad that's pretty good
okay third try was a little better
you guys let me know what you think
please so i hope you enjoyed the episode
that was for you
um and uh again make sure you subscribe
write a review
and now it is time before we go to
read off the patrons top patrons here we
go ryan i'm not going to ask you i'm not
going to put you on the spot because you
know i'm a little brain dead after these
holidays i appreciate it
i'm foggy there we go nancy d leah s
trisha f sarah v
little lisa yukiko jill e brian h lauren
g
nico p robin s jerry w emily k robert i
jason w
stephen j kristen k amelia oh allison l
jess j lucas m raj c joshua d
emily s cjp samantha m jennifer n
jackie p stacy l carly h jennifer s
janelle b
carrie b i feel really tired today
tabitha 272 not to be confused with
tabitha 273 ashley ryan kimberly e
crystal h
mike e marissa and jackass
it's jackass it's jack slate slit slater
ramirez beth b
santiago m sarah f chad w leanne p
roshan ray a maya p maddie s tiffany i
kendrick f ashley e
margie m shannon d matt w
belinda and kevin v james r chris h
anusha w
ospio oshkorn h osborne h gabby m
amy c abc
c easy sorry dave h samantha s
spider-man
chase that's correct sheila g
e g g correct ray h alyssa c
tab of the t misha h debe
deb hey what's up devin thomann
natalie622 not to be confused with
natalie623
correct ally b suzanne b henry s
kdf daniela v liliana a joseph c
michelle k
maddie waggs marcus w hannah b michael s
luke h john s and rob d
a lot of patrons couldn't do it without
you love you stay with me
don't go anywhere i need you i need you
like the winter needs a spring like the
summer needs the rain
i need you um it's all started on again
you know that's america that's one of my
my dad loves america we play that song
dude one of the first songs he ever
taught me on guitar
that's one i need you
[Music]
i need you like the winner needs this
what does it start out with when are you
supposed to laugh we used to cry
we used to bow our heads and
wonder why now you're gone
i guess i'll carry on i know the chords
are better than i know what the words
are you gotta teach me that song
all right we're embarrassing ourselves
i'm embarrassing myself anyway thank you
guys for listening
thank you for a great year even though
it's been a hard year but we got through
it
we're getting through it we have a
glorious year coming to us
stay with it not just with this podcast
stay with
it game plan is to always find the good
in life
and uh no matter how bad it gets there's
gonna be a light there's gonna be fun
moments there's gonna be a good time you
just have to
keep pushing pushing man
i love you all thank you for listening
thank you for supporting this podcast
thank you for allowing me to be inside
of you